[Music]
hi we're live at the 2019 Wolfram
technology conference I'm Silvia Haas
and I'm WolframAlpha on Twitter and I'm
here with my co-host hi I'm reg nama
Steven meant the Illinois Math and
Science Academy and I'm part of the
welcome emerging Leaders program we're
here with Joe frisk who at Haun's who is
a wolfram community moderator and he's
here to talk to us about forest fires in
Brazil so what do you do at Wolfram so
I'm from community moderator website
platform okay
and some from time to time I also like
to go no pickles okay and in this case
it was about Brazil fires bring rain
forests personal fires a little bit more
about the community yeah so it's a
online platform where both from users
can ask and share their own ideas and
there's a rich interaction between
different expertise several community
groups so what are you doing here at the
conference so I'm gonna present a talk
on on one of my hobbies I just like
identifying species like kind of Pokemon
but in the real life and it's gonna be
about the computational taxonomy
even if I'm bigger on is in physics I
like biology
can you tell us a little bit about your
project
so the one we're on a present here it's
a it's about
trying to visualize the the the recent
increasing in in Brazil growing forest
fires which I think it's reserved to
eighty-four percent this year in respect
to the last year and what I wanted to
show is that it's not a natural event
that raised up the temperatures and but
it was more likely politics related and
human origin so maybe I can so the first
step was to to get the the built in data
from Wolfram knowledge base and get all
the different states from Brazil and
then I want to also show where the
people is living in Brazil and you can
see that I think here in the Amazonas
State it's quite not that many people
like in other states like Barra and mato
grosso well actually the rainforest is
also here and so is that why there's not
as many people there yep
and is that all just built into the law
firm language all this first part like
population showing the the just estate
seems or all these entities are building
in in the whorfin language
maybe I can also enlarge and the next
step was to get the the real data that
these the National Institute for Space
Research in Brazil recorded a number of
fires during the last seven years using
satellite images and basically what I
did is to take this data from I trust
this institution and I imported it to
the Wolfram language and then the next
step was to combine both Geographics and
the idea was to visualize the number of
fires initially I use it all so there
was a similar type of visualization with
colors but the friend of mine asked me
like but here I cannot really visualize
how many fires were like in the area so
I decided to use a new a new version 12
from function that I did not know about
it and it was one called
random geo position so I know the number
of fires and then I realized there were
like two many fires at something like
seventy thousand fires so I decided to
to kind of define a red dot into the map
as 20 approximately 25 fires so it would
be like easy to visualize something
there randomly generated within a region
exactly within each state i knew the
number of fires per year so i decided to
reach to represent one record randomly
in that state
and and then that black represent
approximately 25 fires then it was a
matter of tweaking a bit the Geographics
using some geo background a satellite
image using some esthetics tweaking and
the final resolution was a gif yeah so
the three in the last seven years you
can see that in 2019 really there's like
a red light lights and I also ended with
so this is this is why the data is built
in all from language data and you can
specify certain state for example here
in the state of Amazonas you can see
that during the last seven years
actually the temperature beverage
temperature was not really increasing
actually it was even decreasing so there
is no physical evidence for like being
natural this price of values and if we
go back to to the states there's a
period instead the steps near Thomas
O'Neill's are the ones having high
population and they're like probably
right now using burning rainforests to
then use for agriculture soya milk
production beef so it's a it's kind of a
terrible sad news but that's kind of
happening right now
especially during the last year with the
new president in Brazil also Nara so
what prompted you to this project I
think it was like last September
many medias like Instagram or Facebook
you could see a lot of like shocking
videos of rain forest fires but you
don't get the big the bigger picture of
what's really happening there it seems
like there's just like fire in
rainforests but you don't know them the
reason why it's happening in Brazil and
why and what to share it and I think I
said in ready day this beautiful channel
and I got quite viral they're like
several thousand views and some nice
comments or extensions because I think I
could do some extension that's cool so
if people want to learn more about this
so I guess that the next step would be
like to not go to the States but the
subdue be like that mister divisions
inside the states and get maybe a closer
look at the villages and cities that are
within the different regions and so get
more accurate what's really happening
and one maybe would could be like using
several Wolfram language functions that
is like satellite images by something
you can connect also to
- one of the satellite services that
give you every day or almost everyday
life images from from from Earth I
should check in and that would be like
an idea to go to keep keep extending the
project so you could just like keep
adding to it every day I haven't had a
type do you have other projects in the
works right now
yeah preparing with talk for tomorrow
and so maybe one thing I could do is
also since then I'm gonna do some
project umpire diversity to also try to
check like to see these areas that are
getting burned if there are like certain
species that are only living in there is
burned so then if like like maybe
calculating the number of extinct
species you do these fires sad but
interesting because I think it's it's
the only place in Earth's that like the
highest number of species concentrated
for kilometres were in good fires
naturally occur aspires have always
natural and I think it's a natural
process in rainforests it's not that
common to have freedom like fires on
rainforests but it's natural
processing the only were like kind of
alarming thing is that we humans are
raising up that number your project
brings awareness for that thank you good
luck on your talk tomorrow
[Music]